Pro Football Hall of Famer from football
night in America on NBC Tony Dungy how
are you Tony hey rich I'm doing well and
first of all let me tell you I'm running
out of power on my phone all right not
because I don't love you because I ran
out of power oh gosh okay so then let's
get right to it in this Honda insider
quote we're totally done G okay and if
we lose you we lose you what do you
think of the hires starting with Matt
rule in Carolina Tony you know I'm one
who firmly believes if a team does their
research and they they're in on their
guy for the right reasons then god bless
and make it work I remember when John
Harbaugh got hired and people said all
the special teams coach and this doesn't
make sense and Ozzie Newsome knew
exactly what he wanted and it's been
been great so you know these are a
little bit out of the box that rule and
and Joe just but hey I really trust
people making decisions and if they're
doing it because it's what they want and
let it go well I mean as you mentioned
Joe judge at least rule comes in to
Carolina and Carolina fans have heard of
rule and they've seen him and they've
also read all the papers saying what a
hot coaching candidate he is Giants fans
are probably looking up Joe judge this
judge to see if he's related to Wapner
or Judy I know so you know what that's
not all bad sometimes I remember a lot
of people saying who is Chuck Noll who
is Mike Tomlin and you know we'll find
out you know there's plenty of time to
find out Tony Dungy here on the Rich
Eisen show what was your challenge when
you went to become a head coach for the
first time Tony obviously you had a ton
of NFL experience even playing for
somebody like Noah but what what is the
challenge for guys who have never done
it before the biggest challenge is
selling the players and everybody in the
building on your beliefs and having them
gain confidence in you you know I had 15
years as an assistant but still no track
record as an NFL head coach and so
there's always a little skepticism it
was much easier for me the second time
at Indy for sure but you know selling
yourself here
with believing my sister and getting
your assistance everybody else in the
building on Bourne Wow that's gonna be
the challenge for these two guys for
sure Tony Dungy here on the Rich Eisen
show what do you think what do you think
Matt rule can bring I mean I don't know
how much Baylor football you've watched
but well creativity and met a you know
he knows the NFL and he's gonna bring
this creative offense and excitement and
energy and they're gonna move the
football what the challenge is okay how
does that translate to the whole team
and running everything and you know
creating that five not only on the
offense with the defensive special teams
in the scouting Department everywhere
that's what he's gonna have to do but I
think he's gonna do just what Kliff
Kingsbury did and bring an offense
that's gonna be different and unique and
a different skill set and then what do
you what's your best guest that Joe
judge would bring to Daniel Jones and I
imagine his whatever plan he had for
Jones is what helped sell him in the
room along with being from a Saban and
Belichick system but what can you give
any idea of any insider thought on what
what that might look like well I've been
with some great special teams coaches
and the one thing about them is they do
talk to the whole team and they do get
in front of everybody and they connect
with every single player so that is what
he's got going for him and that's that
pedigree said hey here's how we did it
here's how we put together this look
going on we have a blueprint of how to
win now we got to put the pieces
together but hey I know how to win what
do you think Brady's gonna do Tony
the one thing I know he's not going to
do is retire he he wants to play three
more years he doesn't want to go out on
an off year as I said I never thought
Peyton Manning would play in another
uniform besides that vote Colts
horseshoes and he went out to Denver and
had some great years and won a Super
Bowl out there and let the entire thing
and if if worse comes to worse I think
Tom will do that he'll go somewhere else
and set a very high standard
if I were Robert Kraft and Bill
Belichick right now I would say we
Tom Brady back the ball is not you know
is in this Court
we want it back we need them here and
make Tom Brady say no I don't want to
play here before he's it go anyplace
well if he does go someplace else where
do you think would be a viable stop for
him that would fit what he's looking for
in terms of weaponry that he did not
have this year an opportunity to win a
Super Bowl and he's come accustomed to
so as crazy as it sounds the best spot
might be Indianapolis you believe it or
not I know they've been bitter rival but
they've got good young receivers a lot
of speed they've got a great running
back they've got a tremendous offensive
line they've got a defense in place
Jacoby Brissette started off playing
hunted there's no established
quarterback there and they've got a lot
of weapon and they were playoff game
last year so that one to me is as close
as anyone now whether he would you know
consider that I don't know but that
would be a spot like that that I'd look
for if I were ya tebe 12 walking past a
statue of Peyton Manning to go to work
on game day would be interesting but
would be a little crazy but you well I
mean you also speaking of I guess a
little bit crazy you know Jim Irsay so
do you think that he and Chris Ballard
and Frank Reich might actually put their
heads together and say this is feasible
let's see if new league gear hits and TV
12s available let's go for it I tell you
what if I were sitting there with the
team that I have right now and Tom said
he was interested I would definitely I
would I would try to make it happen
makes sense a few more minutes left here
with Tony Dungy the best team left in
the end the eight team now tournament
for Lombardi Trophy is is which I like
Baltimore's you just look at what
they've done they've been so tough to
defend that defense is humming they have
the home-field advantage I think they're
gonna be very very hard to beat well
you're doing NBC the coverage of Vikings
and 49ers how do you see that one
playing out now that Kirk Cousins has
kind of gotten his his first major we
saw what happened with Phil Mickelson
when he finally won his first I'm
wondering
obviously that's you know he doesn't
have the Lombardi Trophy like a green
jacket that Phil had but just a monkey
off the back if you will Tony what do
you think about that yeah and they'd
it's something I didn't think it'd be
done I'm going into New Orleans and
winning it in the dome and Kirk Cousins
has played pretty well when he's had a
full complement of people with him
and this past game was the first time in
a long time that they had cooked stealin
and digs all together and they played
very good on bacon if they could have
that group together they've got a chance
to go into San Francisco and pull this
all and and then the last one for you
here Tony you've been very vocal about
it all year long on my show on yours
with Tirico and the crew football night
in America if the league reached out to
you competition committee reached out to
you and say what should we do
with the rule that we created that makes
pass interference reviewable you would
say what get rid of it yesterday you
know it's a mess trying to review
judgment and then have someone be the
ultimate authority oh well my judgment
it's going to trump the judgment of the
guys on the field I just don't like that
it's been a catastrophe all year now we
had the one opportunity to see it in
place in New Orleans on the last play of
the game clearly offensive pass
interference and it was an overturned I
don't know how they overturn one now
going forward well what about the idea
of you know the catch rule was a total
mess because there really was no rule
you know for years the league basically
said read the rulebook it's right there
everybody I mean and then they finally
did codify it in a way that we have
gotten rid of the catch not a catch
problem what about coming up with an
actual standard for which pass
interference would be reviewed and
called as opposed to what happened this
year I think that that if that gets
handled then maybe we can have this
safety net that's appropriately applied
well the problem is the route the
wording materially restrict an offensive
or defensive player or what does that
mean
what is materially restrict and my
judgment of what is mature
is different obviously the league office
didn't feel like Kyle Rudolph materially
hinder PJ William on Sunday but he did
and so it's just it's judgment it's a
gray area it's always going to be that
way and I think you just there's no way
you're gonna make it perfect Tony we
made it through the segment with you not
needing to recharge your phone so the
power of prayer you you know what and
and we we should get a rich eyes and
show Mophie to Tony Dungy you know so
you can get one of those things just
plug it right in and you can get
official you make it up you know it yeah
but I would love a rich size than one so
that then they want you got it Tony I
hope to see you soon
always enjoy our Channel right back at
you that's Tony Dungy Pro Football Hall
of Fame early for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app